The opening trap of Saw 4 takes place in a
mausoleum, and some of the tomb markers are
named after the crew members who helped make
the movie, like the art department’s painter
Napoleon Forbes, the carpenters Hubert Peddle
and Brian Lumley, and a miscellaneous crew
member named Cris Becker.
It makes sense to see carpenters and painters
immortalize themselves on the physical set,
while someone like the graphic designer Sean
Scoffield got his own name in there on this
fingerprint analysis report.
The head of the forensics department is listed
as David Armstrong, who happens to be Saw
4’s Director of Photography, which is also
considered to be the head of the camera department
and electric department on a movie.
There is also some information on this report
that answers a previously unsolved mystery
about Saw 2, so stick around if you want to
hear about it.
[INTRO]
Welcome to Things You Missed.
Saw 4 represents a transition for the Saw
Franchise.
After the departure of the original writer,
this would be the last Saw movie director
Darren Lynn Bousman would direct for the next
13 years.
But the producers obviously wanted to keep
the series going, and as a result, Saw started
to become more... episodic.
The movie would contain setups that might
not pay off for another two or three movies
and some of them are pretty well kept secrets.
I’m gonna uncover and talk about even more
Things You Missed, so let's put those words.
On your screen.
Right now.
The film opens with John Kramer’s autopsy,
if only this guy knew how valuable that mask
would become in 2020, and the scene sets
up for the big twist of this movie, the fact
that the autopsy is actually the last scene
chronologically, and Saw 4 takes place at
the same time as Saw 3.
The tape in John’s stomach is played for
Detective Hoffman, and you can fully expect
a YouTube video from me in about 70 years
with a similar message.
“You think it’s over just because I’m
dead?
I promise that my work will continue.”
Despite this twist being a surprise to most,
we are constantly shown that time is an important
factor in Saw 4.
From the ancient clock that John emphasizes
to Jill, to the watch he angrily throws away
after losing their unborn son, to the countdown
that looms over this movie’s main game,
to the theme of that game being about time
and patience…
“Time was on your side, but your obsession
wouldn’t let you wait.”
...to many of the lessons that John teaches
to his victims also being about time.
“Give me time to explain, please!”
“I can’t give you time.
No one can.
Time is an illusion.”
But outside of the concept of time, there
are also a lot of clues that the events of
Saw 3 had not yet taken place.
Like the fact that outside of that opening
flash-forward scene, there’s no mention
of John and Amanda’s death, and the most
recent headlines we see are all about the
events of Saw 2, like this one that says “Detective
and Serial Killer Still Missing,” a reference
to Matthews and John literally dipping out
so that John can take the Detective to the Nerve
Gas House.
Also, the photos on the left side are all
photos from John’s workshop at Wilson Steel
Plant.
If this was taking place after John Kramer’s
autopsy, they would also have photos from
the Operation Room.
This magazine cover has an article about Detective
Matthews in relation to Jigsaw, but nothing
about Dr. Denlon, who, by the way is mentioned
off hand in the movie but we don’t know
it’s her at the time.
“Boss, it looks like another doctor went
missing from the hospital.
You think maybe it’s uhh…?”
“Thanks.”
When I heard this line, I thought he was saying
another doctor as in, another doctor in addition
to Dr. Denlon, but it was really another doctor
in addition to Dr. Gordon.
Shortly after, Hoffman is seen holding a children’s
toy.
When asked about it by Agent Perez, he simply
says, “it’s a short story, believe me,”
which is not a lie, but if we look closely
at it, it’s actually one of the toys that
belongs to Corbett Denlon, the kidnapped daughter
from Saw 3.
And the Saw 3 connections really don’t let
up because Saw 4 straight up shows us Hoffman
placing a note for Amanda in the middle drawer
of John’s desk, which is a connection to
this line from the previous movie.
"In my desk.
The center drawer.
An envelope.
Your name on it."
It seems that Darren Lynn Bousman, who I apparently
can’t talk at all about without saying his
full first, middle and last name, was so confident
that we wouldn’t notice these details that
he straight up put the date that this all
takes place on: April 28th 2006.
While we don’t see the exact date in Saw
3, we know it can’t be that long after Saw
2, where “John Kramer was damn near on his
deathbed the last time we saw him.”
We also know that Saw 4 takes place 6 months
after Saw 2.
“Eric’s been missing for 6 months, Kerry’s
been gone for 4 days.”
So the timeline checks out; it makes sense
that 3 and 4 are taking place on the same
day.
Also, the date helps timeline obsessed people
such as myself confirm when Saw 2 actually
takes place, because Saw 4 is stated to be
six months after the disappearance of Eric
Matthews.
Previously, we could only estimate that Saw
2 took place in October 2005, based on the
decomposition of Adam and Zep’s bodies in
the bathroom; they look like they’ve been
rotting for about a year.
But now we have something more concrete.
And it fits right in with this newspaper headline
stating that police have released the identity
of Jigsaw, and it’s published on November
30th.
It makes sense that they would keep it under
wraps after first discovering that John Kramer
was Jigsaw, but after losing him and being
unable to find him for the next month, they
would release his identity to the public.
Also, the writer of this other article is
Jane Kim, the assistant of Darren Lynn Bousman
on this movie.
There’s another article later on written
by Jason Lunn, the leadman of the Art Department.
Of course, the big clue where I think most
of us started to realize that Saw 4 took place
alongside the third installment was at the
end, when Agent Strahm shows up to Gideon
Meat Packing Plant and finds the photo of
Jeff’s family seen in the previous film.
Then there’s more of…
Jeff abusing the lights for some reason.
He really does not like lights, does he?
So there is a lot of evidence to look back
on that proves Saw 4’s timeline placement,
and while Saw 4 isn’t among my favorite
Saw movies, I think there’s something that
I like about giving an iconic entry in a franchise
multiple direct sequels.
It reminds me of the Legend of Zelda franchise,
where they came out with this legendary game,
Ocarina of Time, and gave one sequel in the
timeline branch where Link is a child, and
one sequel in the timeline branch he abandoned
as an adult.
But the interesting thing about Saw 4 is it
not only moves us forward in the timeline,
but also flashes us back to John Kramer’s
past, where we can discover even more Things
You Missed.
When Officer Rigg is watching back the Jill
Tuck interrogation tapes, he does so on reference
monitor B at the police station.
We can also see there is another monitor on
this cart, but the label says 9 inch HD Monitor.
Sometimes in the movie industry, you can get
away with using equipment as props, and this
is probably one of those cases.
In fact, it happens a lot in Saw 4, like later
on at Rigg’s house and maybe here at the
Ice Block Trap, though it’s possible these
Lite Panels were never supposed to be on-screen.
When you make 7 movies in 7 years, that’s
the kind of mistake that can happen.
When we first see the newspaper article about
John buying the Gideon Meat Packing Plant,
there’s actually some nice lore, as opposed
to the first Saw where the contents of the
articles were just random stories.
Apparently, the building had sat abandoned
for 100 years before John purchased it as
part of his Urban Renewal Group project, which
could explain why nobody ever discovered what
he was doing there, and why the majority of
people don't really even know where it was.
“Where is it?
Where is it?
WHERE IS IT?
Where... is it...?
WHERE IS IT?!?"
The main game that we follow during Saw 4
is the Trial of Daniel Rigg, which contained
a lot of parallels to the original Saw.
For example, Rigg’s game begins when he
wakes up in a bathtub, just like Adam Stanheight
when he began his Jigsaw journey.
There would be another Adam parallel later,
when Rigg comes upon a room filled with photos
of the crimes that took place at a slimy motel,
whose red light illumination is very reminiscent
of the darkroom in Adam’s apartment, which
is similarly lined with incriminating candid
photos.
On a side note, Jigsaw’s punishment for
Ivan is to strap him down to this bed?
I mean… does he not realize there are people
who’ll pay good money for that kind of experience.
There are a few more callbacks to the original,
like the question marks seen throughout Rigg’s
adventure, which reference the question mark
painted on Donnie Greco’s stomach for the
reverse bear trap.
I’ve mentioned throughout this series that
the franchise has many instances of a character
playing dead in order to make a surprise attack,
and that comes back again in this one as Detective
Matthews feigns death to get close to his
supposed captor, Art Blank.
And then at the Chinese New Year celebration,
which is of course Year of the Pig, we see
the origin of the pig masks worn by John’s
followers in all four Saw movies.
He starts off by using a more cartoony pig
mask, but in the background there are more
realistic ones like he would eventually come
to use, and what I found very interesting
was another mask with spiral patterns on the
cheeks like that of Billy the Puppet.
This must just be a coincidence though, because
he already had created Billy as a toy for
his unborn child prior to these events.
Unless he had maybe seen this mask elsewhere
before and maybe was inspired by it.
Another likely coincidental connection found
in the Chinese New Year Parade scene is these
little figurines, which can also be seen beside
John’s deathbed in Saw 3.
But back to Rigg.
He comes out of his bathroom to find his house
has been turned into a trap, and the phone
has been taken.
I wonder if Jigsaw re-used the audio of the
voicemail greeting from Saw 2?
“You've reached Daniel’s phone, he's not
in right now but if you--.”
I should start selling those voicemail greetings
on Fiverr or something.
He comes up to his first test subject, Brenda,
who is trapped in the scalp chair, and he
discovers the three digit combination to release
her.
“Six-four-seven, six-four-seven!”
The number is a little nod to the area code
in Toronto where movies 2-9 were filmed.
It’s kind of frustrating that Jigsaw could
have been like the ultimate crime fighting
machine and instead became the ultimate crime
committing machine.
I mean he could have easily just taken these
photos to the police… same with the videotape
of Ivan.
But no, he’s gotta go and put them in literal
torture devices.
So Rigg follows the path that Jigsaw set out
for him while Strahm also goes down the trail
of Jigsaw’s clues, but also stops to interrogate
Jill Tuck, at the beginning of which he looks
like he’s posing for a CZsWorld Instagram
photo.
*metal music*
She tells him more stories about John’s
past including some that took place at her
drug clinic, where we see younger versions
of some of the criminals from Jigsaw’s traps.
Gus Colyard, the guy who was taken out by
the Magnum Eyehole trap in Saw 2, gets into
a fight in the waiting room; Addison Corday,
the woman who fell victim to the Razor Box
trap, tries to get John to solicit prostitution
from her as he’s waiting outside; and Troy,
the man who met his demise in the classroom
trap in Saw 3, also seems to be a patient
or at least be connected to a patient of the
Homeward Bound Clinic.
The phase of Rigg’s trial brings him to
a different classroom, where he discovers
where a husband and wife are impaled with
a series of spikes.
I think there’s a common misconception here,
which people love to clown on, that the woman
is being tested because she allowed her husband
to abuse her.
The way Jigsaw phrases it in the tape does
kind of make it seem like that is the case,
but I think people forget that this is the
same couple from the elementary school flashback,
so it was probably more about the woman keeping
quiet knowing that her husband was abusing
the students.
"He's done this before.
She's allowing it."
I’m not saying that makes it any better,
or that she deserves to be punished or anything,
but I’m just trying to explain what might
have been going through Jigsaw’s head.
I can’t really explain what was going through
Strahm’s head during the quick flashes while
he’s interrogating Jill.
*dramatic horn*
Yeah… that’s weird… should we, like…
call someone?
Throughout the series there have been traps
that were inspired by ancient torture devices,
and you couldddd say that The Knife Chair
that John puts Cecil into was one of them,
though it’s not exactly the same as this
Chinese torture chair from the early 1900s,
because Jigsaw’s version gives the victim
the ability to decide if they want to hurt
themselves in order pass.
There’s also a trap we see in John’s workshop,
which doesn’t get used until a future movie.
The Glass Coffin would come back in Saw 5
and a key around Jill’s neck during the
scenes that take place in 2006, would also
return in a future film.
There’s another Saw Horror History episode
coming this Wednesday, then it looks like
I’ll have to put the Saw content on hold
for a little bit while we wait for Spiral
to get a new release date, so if you want
to make sure you’re notified when I resume
with even more Things You Missed in Saw 5,
6, 7, Jigsaw and Spiral then make sure you
subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.